how do we use AI to increase our output
and make more money today adopt the
mentality that AI isn't here to replace
me it's here to supercharge me if you
don't you'll be like those Boomers who
don't want to use an iPhone or the
internet you have to embrace change it's
part of humanity technology moves we got
to adapt you can 10x or even 100 extra
output if AI can condense our inputs so
if I say hey go read this book distill
it down and then give it to me I can now
read a book significantly faster if I
say hey ai go summarize all my email and
all my stock messages and just tell me
the few that I need to respond to and
predict what I'm going to say and then
all I need to do is validate it I can do
a days worth of work in a few minutes